من طهران بمدير مكتب الجزيره عبد القادر
فايز الذي ينضم الينا في هذه التغطيه عبد
القادر اذا كيف تتابع طهران هذه
الضربات محمد رسميا حتى الان لم تتحدث
ايران عن كل ما يجري في سوريا والعراق وفي
المنطقه والضربات الامريكيه في تلك
المناطق لا بالمعنى العسكري ولا حتى
بالمعنى السياسي ولكن هذا لا يعني بان
ايران لا تتابع وعن قرب شديد ما يجري خاصه
وبان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتحدث
بشكل واضح بان كل ما يجري في سوريا
والعراق من هذه الضربات بانها انتقاميه
بالدرجه الاولى صحيح على ما جرى في قاعده
البرج 22 ولكن ايضا ردع بالنسبه لايران
وتتحدث بشكل واضح بانها تستهدف ما تسميه
بمواقع لفيلق القدس والحرس الثوري في
سوريا ول حلفاء لايران في تلك المنطقه
سواء في سوريا او في العراق وتحديدا على
الحدود العراق العراقيه السوريه لذلك يمكن
ان نقول بان هناك متابعه حثيثه لكل ما
يجري في تلك المنطقه من قبل ايران ولكن
محمد اشير اريد ان اشير الى نقطتين
اساسيتين بالنسبه لايران عندما تتحدث
ايران عن الخطوط الحمراء فحقي هنا في
طهران يتم الكلام بان كل ما يجري الان هو
في سياق ما كان يجري سابقا وبانه لم يتم
تجاوز خطوط حمراء وازنه جدا بمعنى انه
القوات الامريكيه تتحدث بشكل واضح
بانها لن توجه ضربات الى الداخل الايراني
الى الجغرافيا الايرانيه وهذا مهم جدا
بالنسبه لايران لانه محدد اساس في عمليه
الى اين ستذهب كل هذه الضربات الامريكيه
النقطه الثانيه يمكن ان نقول بان ايران
ترى بان هذه الضربات هي انتهاك لثلاثه
عواصم عربيه في ذات الوقت تماما عندما
نتحدث عن اليمن والعراق و سوريا وبان
القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه تهاجم هذه
العواصم الثلاث انطلاقا من انها تريد ان
تقوم بتدعيم منظومه رضعيه جديده هل هذا
سيحدث حقيقه على ارض الواقع هذا غير مفهوم
حتى الان على الاقل لم نسمع اي شيء
بالنسبه
يران ما تحدثت عنه القوات الامريكيه بانها
استهدفت ما اسمته بفيلق القدس في سوريا
حقيقه هناك تساؤلات مهمه هل نتحدث عن
استهداف لاشخاص في فيلق القدس لضباط وقاده
في فيلق القدس في سوريا ام نتحدث عن
استهداف مواقع تابعه لفيلق القدس في سوريا
او مواقع تابعه لحلفاء فيلق القدس في
سوريا لذلك هذه اسئله مهمه حقيقه في مثل
هذه المرحله نعلم تماما بان ايران لا
تمتلك قواعد ربما صرفه لها داخل سوريا
بمعنى قواعد ايرانيه صرفه تابعه فقط للحرس
الثوري وفيلق القدس هناك تنوع للقواعد الع
العسكريه على الاراضي السوريه والعراقيه
لما تسميه ايران بمحور المقاومه بمعنى
اننا نجد قاعده ما سيتواجد فيها
المستشارين الايرانيين العسكريين
الايرانيين وكذلك عسكريين من بقيه محور
المقاومه كحزب الله والقوات السوريه
وكذلك المقاومه العراقيه لذلك حقيقه ما
يجري الان في سوريا من وجهه النظر
الايرانيه حتى الان غير واضح على ما الذي
يتم استهدافه بالضبط وعن ماذا تتحدد تتحدث
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عندما تقول
بانها تستهدف الفيلق القدس في سوريا لاننا
ندرك تماما بان فيلق القدس حاضر في سوريا
انطلاقا من مستشارين عسكريين وكذلك من
مساعدات لوجستيه اخرى لبقيه محور المقاومه
انطلاقا من الاراضي السوريه لا ننسى محمد
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحدثت عن
هذه الضربات لاكثر من خمسه ايام تقريبا
وهي تقول بانها ستوجه هذه الضربات في
الحقيقه هذا وقت كافي عندما يتحدث بعض
المحللين وهم على حق في ذلك هذا وقت كافي
بالنسبه لايران لتعيد ترتيب الاوراق لها
في سوريا اذا ما ارادت ان تقوم بانسحاب ما
من الاراضي السوريه من سحب قيادات ما من
الاراضي السوريه والعراقيه فهي تستطيع ان
تفعل ذلك ولكن اعود الى صياغه الموقف
الرسمي الايراني حقيقه ايران ترى في كل ما
تقوم به الولايات المتحده هو اعتداء
بالدرجه الاولى وكذلك هو توجيه ضربات
لحلفاء لها في هذه المنطقه وتقول بشكل او
باخر بان هؤلاء قد يردوا في المستقبل على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكان ذلك س
سيرد ايضا من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهكذا يدخل المنطقه في دوا بكل
فاز ناقش